south-central baby it's no game and I
can teach you how to fight but sometimes
your best weapons are your words you
ever thought I get this close to a
vagina until I was at least 10 we
started this gym to keep kids off the
streets
we're doing good don't let the beta
build then listen me and uncle Lee are
we in here for bank robbery how much man
million dollar the money's in the wall
in this flophouse in the basement what
happens I'm gonna get him by joining the
fraternity greetings gentlemen I'm here
to rush got a perfect name to fit into
paternity C shut buttersworth your
pledge master I'm about to see who has
what it takes white people they're
terrified of being called racist first
thing you slaves are gonna do in Corning
I'm not sure we should call the pledge
of slaves this year isn't it more racist
to change our traditions simply cuz we
got a black place I'm so glad we're
finally having this discussion
uncle Lee y'all got my money yeah money
nope I mean she do be liking my pictures
on Instagram late at night why you guys
weren't in Klan robes no our fraternity
actually predates the plan by over a
decade so why are they wearing our robes
yeah y'all wearing Klan robes
it's super confusing being a white man
in today's society okay any black people
I brought the bus oh my god how was you
doing that it's not what it looks like
looks like you got yourself caught up in
some races for ten people well then is
exactly what it looks like so I'll
charity galas coming up we're gonna make
you the auctioneer now my great great
great great granddaddy would love to
hear me say this get your bill folks out
cuz we buy white people today
[Music]
you